[Musique]
c'est une importante percée dans la
recherche sur l'Alzheimer qui vient
d'être confirmé Mariam on parle d'un
premier médicament il faut toujours être
prudent mais là voyons ça comme une
lueur d'espoir
qui ralentirait la progression de la
maladie exactement Marc-André parce que
depuis des années il y a des recherches
sur l'Alzheimer qui ont mené à des
échecs alors devoir comme ça un résultat
qui est probant c'est extrêmement
encourageant ce sont des résultats qui
ont été dévoilés dans le cadre d'un
congrès à San Francisco hier et ce qu'on
apprend c'est que le médicament les
canemap qui a été développé par les
pharmaciennes japonaises et américaines
essaie et biogène ben réussi à ralentir
le déclin cognitif chez des gens qui
sont au premier stade ou dans les
premiers stades de la maladie
d'Alzheimer alors on parle de 27% de
ralentissement quand même cette étude
qui a été menée sur près de 1800
personnes pendant 18 mois ils ont reçu
des perfusions à chaque deux semaines
maintenant c'est de voir à quel point ça
va durer dans le temps mais pour
l'instant quand même on est heureux de
voir ses résultats dans le monde de la
médecine d'ailleurs on a un de nos
collègues de CBC qui a rencontré l'une
des participantes à cette étude je vous
invite à l'écouter
justement la protéine dont parle madame
Klein je vais vous expliquer son rôle
dans la maladie de l'Alzheimer pour que
vous compreniez comment ce médicament
agit alors regardez bon sur ce graphique
vous voyez dans un cerveau atteint
d'Alzheimer on retrouve la protéine
betta amyloïde d'en parler madame Clyde
il y en a davantage autour des neurones
d'une personne atteinte de la maladie et
ça ça fait en sorte que d'en trouver
autour des neurones ça ralentit la
communication dans le cerveau le passage
de l'information alors le rôle du
lycanémable qui est un anticorps on
l'envoie dans le corps et il va
s'accrocher comme ça aux protéines en
question et par la suite ça fait en
sorte que ça attire des cellules du
système immunitaire alors c'est celle-là
vont aller décomposer les protéines et
résultat il y en a moins autour des
neurones alors on retrouve un cerveau
qui est plus simple aussi simple que ça
c'est simplifié certainement mais c'est
comme ça que ça agit ce médicament là
maintenant c'est certain qu'on ne parle
pas d'une solution miracle il y a des
effets secondaires qui ont été constatés
on parle de risque de
micro-hémorragie il y a 7% des
participants du traitement qui ont dû
d'ailleurs arrêter le processus en
raison de ces effets secondaires mais
reste que il y a quand même eu des
résultats je vous disais 27 % de
ralentissement du déclin cognitif et on
sait qu'il y a énormément de gens qui
sont atteints de l'Alzheimer en ce
moment sur la planète on parlerait de
plus de 55 millions de personnes et
d'ici 2050 les experts s'attendent à ce
qu'il y en aient environ 139 millions
alors le temps de presse maintenant vous
savez que c'est long à prouver des
médicaments les pharmaceutiques dans le
cadre du lycanément envisage de
commencer le processus dans les
prochains mois aux États-Unis en Europe
alors on verra si ça passera mais ce
qu'il faut retenir ce matin c'est que
déjà on a un résultat probant il y a une
lueur d'espoir en ce qui concerne la
recherche sur l'asmure de sport au bon
merci pour aller retrouver le docteur la
docteur Noah bendaid qui est directrice
de recherche et développement à
génération québécoise des sociétés
d'Alzheimer c'est une nouvelle docteur
quand on écoute ça ça doit être très
émouvant pour bien des gens là qui sont
auprès de gens qui ont des des
diagnostics comme ça d'Alzheimer ou qui
ont qui ont qui souffrent de cette
maladie instable c'est toute une
personne
effectivement merci de me recevoir ce
matin justement pour en parler avec vous
surtout que les dernières deux années là
ont été quand même assez éprouvante en
termes de résultats négatif il y a eu
des beaucoup d'annonces qui ont mené un
certain espoir pour justement essayer de
trouver un traitement curatif pour la
maladie d'Alzheimer ou en tous les cas
un médicament qui permettrait de
ralentir le déclin cognitif et ça a été
des échecs à chaque fois donc là
aujourd'hui l'annonce était vraiment
très attendu hier la présentation des
ailes justement lors de la cette
conférence internationale était très
attendue puisqu'on savait que les
résultats allaient être positifs là on
se rend compte que quand même le déclin
cognitif et diminuer de plus de 27% par
rapport au groupe placebo qui avait
également une efficacité sur le temps et
donc forcément ça nous amène à penser
que c'est peut-être la molécule qu'on
attendait ou en la percer majeure que
l'on attendait le fameux ralentissement
de la maladie de 27% ça peut être un peu
abstrait pour plusieurs d'entre nous ça
peut vouloir dire quoi par exemple parce
que vous le calculez en terme de
capacité ou en termes de moi ou d'année
comment comment on peut l'apprécier
alors en fait ils ont fait deux à deux
niveaux en fait il y a eu une diminution
du déclin cognitif notamment par rapport
au placebo donc ça c'est donc c'était en
fait un essai clinique randomisé à
double aveugle donc ni le patient ni les
médecins ne savaient quelle molécule
prenez les patients et puis par rapport
au groupe placebo qui lui prenait encore
un inhibiteur de la sétile
ou bien la même intime qui sont en fait
les médicaments qui sont initialement
prescrits pour les personnes atteintes
de la maladie d'Alzheimer ils ont pu
comparer en fait le déclin cognitif sur
une échelle bien particulière pour
évaluer la qualité la différence par
rapport à ceux qui prenaient les caméras
versus ceux qui ne le prennent pas donc
ça c'est déjà une première une première
donnée à savoir la réduction du déclin
cognitif mais également sur le temps à
savoir que ceux qui sur une période
donnée ils ont également suivi les sur
une période donnée et la même chose ils
ont pu observer une diminution donc du
déclin cognitif surtout que déjà sur la
phase 2 de cette étude clinique il y
avait aussi un modèle un modèle
une estimation qui permettait d'évaluer
quel était le potentiel de l'économie
sur le temps et sur cette base de
modélisation ils peuvent actuellement
dire que sur un délai de trois ans il
pourrait y avoir en fait une
amélioration du déclin cognitif par
rapport au groupe placebo donc tout ça
bien sûr reste à être à être évalué dans
la vraie vie si le médicament est
approuvé par la FDA donc ça ça sera la
première le premier test pour les
cannements et puis par la suite s'ils
vont aller avec d'autres instances pour
déposer des demandes de mise sur le
marché on l'espère également que ça va
venir au Canada donc on voit non
seulement qu'il y a un déclin cognitif
sur la période de laisser clinique donc
les 18 mois mais également on pourrait
potentiellement avoir aussi un déclin
cognitif qui se perdure sur le temps
pouvant aller jusqu'au 3 ans donc c'est
vraiment pour les personnes qui ont un
trouble reconnutif léger ou la forme
légère de la maladie d'Alzheimer une
personne majeure puisqu'on sera non
seulement en mesure de maintenir une
certaine qualité de vie des fonctions
cognitives qui sont assez stables ils
ont également pu montrer qu'il y avait
un effet sur l'épuisement l'épuisement
du crochet dans donc ça aussi ce n'est
pas négligeable donc vous voyez tous les
tous les feux sont au vert donc on
espère là maintenant voir la prochaine
étape là avec avec donc une demande
auprès de la FDA d'autant plus que cette
essais clinique a été aussi particulier
dans le sens que les patients qui ont
été impliqués avaient des commodidités
ils avaient du diabète de l'hypertension
des maladies cardiovasculaires et ils
ont pu également montrer chez ces
personnes là un effet bénéfique sur les
fonctions cognitives et le
fonctionnement
et également grande nouveauté il y avait
également des personnes de la communauté
américaine
noire afro afro-américaine pardon et de
la communauté hispanique chose qu'on ne
voit pas généralement dans les essais
cliniques donc c'est quand même que
c'est que c'est quand même très
diversifié et que ça pourrait
potentiellement effectivement toucher
beaucoup de personnes là si ça va de la
vendre toute une palette alors là
maintenant on va laisser les gens faire
les tests deux trois ans probablement
avant qu'il y ait une commercialisation
ou une utilisation et entre temps on
travaille sur les hypothèses en espérant
que le médicament pourra servir à des
gens qui sont dans un état plus avancé
il y en a qui des médecins qui pensent
que peut-être que oui peut-être que non
alors on va garder espoir c'est ça qu'il
faut retenir comme message ce matin
docteur merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là ce matin
juste pour préciser ils ont déjà
mentionné qu'ils allaient déposer en
fait leur demande à la FDA avant la fin
de l'année fiscale soit mars 2023 ah bon
bah déjà on fait du progrès parfait
merci beaucoup au revoir merci merci à
vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
[Musique]